and now influence squandered that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now during 2020 all we heard was how
important it was to restore america's
leadership position in the world and
that only joe biden had the experience
and the credibility to do this
joe biden is probably the most
experienced foreign policy expert
since
george h.w bush president-elect biden is
doing everything that he can to reassure
the world that american global
leadership is coming back he's thinking
about global leadership about how to
keep everybody safe joe biden will
restore our battered standing in the
world
because he knows that our true strength
comes from setting an example that the
world wants to follow
oh my god watching it
but what we've seen in 14 months is a
series of unsteady moves from an
unstable chief executive and we're also
stuck with the vice president who
literally has zero talent and zero
relevant experience at a time and place
that requires a great deal of both
so did white house chief of staff ron
klain actually think that sending kamala
harris to poland would somehow
intimidate vladimir putin
the woman who speaks as if she's
narrating a sesame street sketch
i am here
standing
here on the northern flank on the
eastern flank talking about what we have
in terms of the eastern flank and our
nato allies and what is at stake at this
very moment
what is at stake this very moment
are some of the guiding principles
around the nato alliance
if only the translator could have told
us what president duda of poland was
really thinking when listening to her
drone on in the tutorial
now the fact is as this third-rate band
of radicals bluster on about zero carbon
emissions and the global equity agenda
other nations including our so-called
allies are busy pursuing their own
interests
just a few years ago they had to contend
with a different type of american
president who knew
how he wasn't afraid to flex our muscle
and our economic might when necessary
who knew how to do that
and have been
very very
direct with secretary staltenberg
and members of the alliance
in saying that nato members must finally
contribute
their fair share
and meet
their financial obligations
but 23 of the 28 member nations
are still not paying what they should be
paying this is not fair to the people
and taxpayers of the united states
what a different world we're living in
now nato members are generally aligned
against russia but only because the
europeans have belatedly realized
they're danger certainly not because of
anything that biden or his team in
blinken did every recent action they
took against putin is in their own
geopolitical interest
and when the biden team suggested that
they stop buying russian energy
germany said no
germany needs russian oil and gas and
frankly they don't care what joe biden
there once was a time when american
president called our allies would listen
or at least they'd pay attention
now they're just tuning biden's team out
altogether
now take india supposedly the
centerpiece of our diplomacy in the
indo-pacific region
india refused to condemn the ukraine
invasion at the united nations despite
our lobbying
now if india is worried about offending
anyone it seems they're most worried
about offending russia while also
keeping an eye on china's ever-looming
presence
they certainly don't care about what joe
biden thinks
the biden team's so-called diplomacy is
nothing more than a series of photo ops
it certainly never yields any results
take saudi arabia
now under trump diplomacy over years was
deft enough to produce the abraham
accords
well looks like biden has squandered
that working relationship as well
the journal is reporting that saudi
prince mohammed bin salman declined a
request to speak with president biden
recently that report is inaccurate so
let me start there
the president did speak with the saudi
king
just a few weeks ago several weeks ago
this is totally humiliating they
wouldn't take his call now think about
it the saudi government is literally too
busy to answer biden's call
we have never seen anything like this
at least maybe not since 1979 or so
now veteran negotiators who really
wanted to help the ukrainians instead of
simply trying to move the polls at home
they would recognize that the only
practical way to stop this invasion now
is by getting china's president xi to
stop putin
because without china's help on trade
russia
couldn't sustain its barbaric and
inhumane assault against ukrainian
cities
but to the ccp the biden team is just a
little more than a joke at this point
and i've got to say who who can blame
them for thinking that because for years
biden was a cheerleader for the ccp
his climate czar and his treasury
secretary are still on team china in
fact today we learned that biden is
rewarding china by delaying a key trade
investigation which would have been the
trigger for tariffs like those trump had
put in place
so the pro-china forces in the
administration at treasury and commerce
they won out as we predicted they would
signaling more weakness to beijing
so why would china ever take america
seriously when our own government is so
easy to intimidate
china lied about kovid china's
supporting russia's invasion of ukraine
but joe and his team they just don't
care
and poor old secretary blanket i almost
feel bad for him knowing his boss will
never use or even look for leverage over
china he can only basically do wishful
thinking diplomacy
spent about hour on the phone with my
counterpart the chinese foreign minister
the other day and one of the things that
i said to him is that you know china
speaks often about the the sanctity of
this principle of sovereignty we would
expect china based on everything it said
uh in the past uh to stand up and make
its voice heard
i stand up and make your voice heard
chyna it's more embarrassment now if
biden was really the leader of a
democrat establishment and what they
sold him as
he would have assembled a team of
foreign policy realists
who would have provided a frank
assessment of the options available in
ukraine
they would have told him that the entire
idea of a rules-based international
order is folly when you have china and
russia smashing up your global playpen
but of course biden's never been a
leader
he's been a glad-handing grifter a
creature of washington
where so much of what passes as
leadership is really just choreography
you got the big desk you have the
conference room you have the lectern
with the presidential seal
it's all props zero substance
and in the real world where serious
people play for keeps
he has been measured
and well found to be weak
no one not one single bad guy on earth
fears joe biden
so the grown-ups the countries who
understand power and how the world
really works
they'll make the key decisions in
ukraine so the europeans the russians
the ukrainians and the chinese will be
at the table
we'll just have to take whatever
arrangement they eventually make
and after all anyone who would send
kamala harris to eastern europe at this
moment in history
cannot be taken seriously and so they
aren't
but someday america will again have a
president who stands up for our
interests and someday we'll again have a
cabinet filled with serious leaders who
know how to use our leverage to make the
world a better place
but that's not going to happen until
after 2024
and in the meantime america is going to
continue to drift as sad as it is to see
and the world will continue to become
more dangerous
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else